we've been analyzing and reviewing the
results from Super Tuesday and these are
not good results for the progressive
movement of the United States and it's
really important when we look at these
results to contextualize them not only
in terms of what they mean in terms of
issue oriented questions like support
for Medicare for all which is still high
or support for particular college
policies or whatever but it also needs
to be looked at in the context of some
of the coalition's and labeled groups
that exist and I went into detail about
the results already I won't do it again
Joe Biden building a lead of about 70
delegates over Bernie right now and
based on the polling in the remaining
states still to vote it is an uphill
battle for Bernie Sanders this is now
not about these results but the bigger
picture we knew this would happen in the
sense that we knew they'd try it right
there was a question of whether it would
work to try to coalesce the
establishment vote and so far it worked
you heard all sorts of analyses for the
last six months about Bernie's ceiling
is like 18 and then Bernie gets to 20
and that Bernie's ceiling is like 23 and
then Bernie gets the 25 and then
Bernie's ceiling is 30 and then he gets
to 31 and 32 in some national polls but
there was a question of whether is there
some ceiling and when you look at Biden
cratering in the polls and focusing on
South Carolina the first racially
diverse state you have to start to say
if there is a ceiling for Bernie this is
an interesting way to test it by
focusing in on that first more racially
diverse state arguably more
representative of some other parts of
the country and the Democratic
electorate so Joe Biden got that boost
from congressman Clyburn winning in
South Carolina by a bigger margin than
the polls suggested and what that meant
was that voters were thinking okay if I
don't want Bernie Warren is increasingly
weak basically Biden is my choice then
Pete dropped out well if you weren't
already with Bernie then Pete dropping
out more than likely pushes you to Joe
by
if Amy drops out which she did and
endorses Joe Biden well that's more
support for Joe Biden so the question
was is there a significant amount of the
support for other candidates Pete and
Amy as an example that would go to
Bernie Sanders or is Biden going to get
the lion's share of Amy and Pete's
supporters does a big rally with Amy and
Beto O'Rourke gets the Pete endorsement
and then they get the results they want
on Super Tuesday with Biden even winning
some states outright like Texas and
Minnesota where he was supposed to lose
he was going to get delegates but he was
supposed to lose those states so now
there's all sorts of enlightened
analyses coming out of the woodwork you
know the DNC establishment stole it
Bernie's campaign was ganged up on it
was voter suppression insiders don't
want Bernie to be the nominee corporate
media has been boosting Biden and
hurting Bernie all along and every
single one of those has some truth to it
there is no question but we also have to
realize that bernie is not merely the
victim here because if we don't
recognize that the progressive movement
will never win and that would be a
tragedy when we see Bernie not take PAC
money we love it it's the right thing to
do it's morally correct
lots of House seats have been won in
that way but every decision has some
risk associated with it when Bernie
doesn't play these inside baseball party
politics games with the Democratic Party
where they coordinate they say let's get
Pete out let's figure out how to stop
this cannon let's get Bernie out on this
day get a me out on this state to
endorse I love that Bernie doesn't play
those games he just runs his campaigns
he tells it like he sees it he says what
he would do he puts together policy
Bernie is loved because he doesn't play
those games but in a lot of the real
world sometimes you need to play those
games to get into a position of power in
the first place to then change the
system so when we say the establishment
stole it there's no doubt the DNC
establishment coordinated this 96-hour
plan of consolidating Amy and Budaj edge
around a Joe Biden of course it was
fabricated and planned but it only works
if there's enough centrist or
center-left support to make it possible
and it was so we have to
recognize that when we spend time on
Twitter and reddit we get an overly
optimistic assessment of the portion of
the National Democratic a letter
electorate who wants someone like Bernie
that's not an attack on Bernie there's
lots of candidates that are liked excuse
me getting very fired up and punching my
Mike there's lots of candidates that are
liked and disliked by different
electorates it doesn't tell us if
they're good or bad candidates but we
have to recognize that if you ask people
about Medicare for all people are
increasingly for it you ask people about
free college people are increasingly for
it there are lots of people who don't
want Bernie to be the nominee and a lot
of them voted last night when so many
people come out and vote for someone
other than Bernie we can't just say
people are confused and they were
tricked by the DNC and bla bla bla bla
bla because then we will not win if
that's what we do if we just say we are
the victims and everybody else's has
either been bamboozled or whatever the
case may be when you look at people
supporting Biden Pete and Amy throughout
the campaign and not going to Bernie we
tried to ignore it but there is this
total amount of center-left ideology in
the Democratic Party Medicare for all
more popular than ever free college you
zoom out and there are millions of
Democrats who believe in what they call
capitalism and they hear democratic
socialism and they don't like it
socialism viewed more favorably now than
in decades but there are lots of
Democratic primary voters who believe in
what they see as moderation this is not
an attack on anybody this is not praise
for anybody
it's assessing the electorate Bernie bet
on a ton of new voters that he could
bring out but new voters voted by
roughly the same proportion as in 2016
in some states lower new voter turnout
there is a race at racial analysis to be
made Bernie one Hispanic voters with 50%
he only got 15 percent of the black vote
yesterday 60% four by Biden young voters
a lot stayed home another group Bernie
was counting on and then lastly there is
something to be said just more broadly
about coalition's and the people that
different
candidates get involved with and sort of
the the note that that the chord that
that strikes with a more casual follower
of politics I've talked about some of
the toxic people around Bernie I can see
past it because I care about policy and
I believe Bernie has the right policies
but all over my facebook page and
Twitter account
there were people telling me you know
David I agree with Bernie the most every
time I do one of these tests about whose
policy is closest to yours but I don't
want to implicitly approve of the toxic
people Bernie has around him and they
said so I ended up voting for Biden so
if you said to me well how could Bernie
have fixed it that would require me to
tell you that Bernie should have been
someone other than who he is the last
thing I'm going to tell you is Bernie
should be inauthentic because bernie is
all about authenticity
he calls himself a Democratic Socialist
he has the people around him that he
wants around him Bernie refuses to do
the inauthentic stuff and this was the
result okay
tons of people have been saying Bernie
needs a one-on-one against someone else
in the primary and then he'll do really
well it became very quickly a de facto
one-on-one of course Bloomberg taking
votes from Biden and Warren likely
taking votes from Bernie we now have to
go through Florida and New York and
Michigan with what is going to
effectively be a two-person race and it
may actually be one very soon there's
one other important number here which is
the popular vote right now Joe Biden has
received nearly a million votes more
than Bernie if you look at the
percentages Joe Biden has received 24%
more votes than Bernie in these
primaries when you see that it has to be
more than just the establishment played
delegate games to sneak Biden more
delegates we can't ignore it if we in
the progressive movement ignore these
numbers we will lose now Joe Biden may
be the nominee and is very very possible
he will lose to Donald Donald from
anyway we'll talk about that that that's
a different argument but I think it's
important for the progressive movement
to have a healthy and accurate
assessment of what is going on here and
not resort to the sort of self
victimizing and blaming every
else for what took place that's not
going to get us anywhere and I don't
want to see that done tell me where you
disagree with me I'm ready I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman